without farmers no food with that slogan
farmers took their tractors to food
distribution centers around the country
blocking refrigerated trucks from
delivering food to thousands of
supermarkets i'm the driver mining giant
we think that people should experience
what farmers are experiencing right now
euron williams was forced to sell his
farm last year because he couldn't earn
enough money with his 50 cows and meet
government limits on emissions
i'm part of the fourth generation of
farmers in our family and that you have
to give that up is very difficult
it is estimated that around 5 000
farmers will have to sell their farms
especially those who live close to
natural parks they will have to cut
nitrogen emissions coming from animal
feces by up to 70 per farm research has
shown that nitrogen emissions have
severely damaged air quality and
ecosystems in the netherlands after
decades of intensive farming now radical
action is needed to meet european
emission targets after years of farmers
protests over government plans the
conflict has escalated in recent weeks
the effects of these farmers protests
are increasingly being fouled by the
dutch public after weeks of blocking
highways and some confrontations with
police now they're targeting the very
core of society food while a recent
survey suggests that public support for
these actions have gone up the question
is now will this trend continue the
association for supermarkets have asked
police to end the blockades as soon as
possible they say it's not only shops
being affected but that hospitals and
other institutions could soon start
running out of food
they are right and if they think they
have to do this just do it only problem
is that our supermarkets may be empty
but then at least we know where the food
is coming from
i understand why they're protesting
question is how much it disrupts society
if citizens start to suffer there'll be
a limit to what people will accept
farmers say they will continue the
blockades until the government changes
its emission plan
we don't have much choice i don't know
if it will have any effect i hope so we
don't want to disrupt everything but as
things are now we have nothing to lose
the threat to paralyze the country and
block access to skipper airport and
rotterdam port did not materialize but
without any solution inside farmers are
likely to continue to take to the
streets with their tractors and wooden
shoes step fasten in nike